clairefontaine vendredi 12
15h28 quartier général de la force
d'observation ils sont tous là berg le
chinois morland devismes les africains
chaudard l'américain et domenech
l'européen oms
sauf un aimé jacquet dit le colonel lui
il est déjà sur le terrain en arabie
saoudite il s'est glissé dans une
réception diplomatique
tous les amateurs de bons romans
d'espionnage savent que c'est là que
tout se joue seulement observé l'équipe
d'arabie saoudite c'est dangereux
sultan le prince fils du roi fahd en est
le patron
qu'y at il donc dans le carnet secret du
colonel ses collaborateurs l'ont ils
seulement ouvert une fois alors aimer
pour nous en exclusivité s'il vous plaît
ouvrez donc votre carnet secret je note
d'une manière très succincte mais très
précises pour des observations
ici c'est tout le clip tout est ici mais
l'école les organisations des qui poussa
ici après je passe ici dans ce domaine
ouvert où l'âge est là bien entendu
l'équipe que je que je suis au maroc
j'ai toute sa composition est ici à la
baisse au lit par exemple ça nous
intéresse à plusieurs
après j'ai les petits petits terrains
qui sont offertes par la télé avec ça ou
je consigne toutes les organisations les
coups de pied stratégique les évolutions
et puis et puis à et temps en temps je
prends une feuille un peu plus cartonné
pour pouvoir être un peu plus
et pendant que son deuxième bureau
décortique le match en direct
lui et melvin sur l'instant il n'y a
rien de tel que de marquer dans les
veines barachois parce que le temps
efface et on oublie certains passifs et
comme tout est pointu précis que c'est
le détail qui fait gagner et au mieux
avec là dedans c'est l'accumulation de
ces petits détails qui fera qui fait la
différence donc il a une obligation lui
de centraliser tout ça d'être au courant
de tous pour informer les joueurs on le
rappelle toujours c'est quand même ce
type d'information c'est pas juste pour
que l'entraîneur il se les met dans un
carton et les garde dans son petit
carnet tout est analysé aucun match qui
passe à la télé n'échappe à michael
alias caporal berliet michael l'oeil de
la force d'observation il y à aussi
l'homme des dossiers des synthèses le
regard du technicien jean françois jodar
moi je met par exemple les joueurs clés
leurs caractéristiques surtout les
attaquants la manière d'un petit se
déplacer s'ils ont un type de fans bien
particulier bon mais je crois que ce qui
peut intéresser mais c'est ce qu'il
recherche c'est d'avoir des girelles
âneries différent à chaque fois
à chacun sa mission mais au fait les
avis sont ils toujours concordants
sacchi rien de pire que d'avoir des
adjoints qui sont toujours d'accord avec
tout ce qu'on dit de temps en temps
c'est bien d'avoir des gens qui nous
disent moi je ferais pas ça ou je le
ferai comme ça et alain qui doit prendre
la décision et celui là c'est toujours
le sélectionneur sait aimé jacquet et
mais qui d'autre part dans sa mallette
possède l'armé absolue version pierre
salviac internet site de coupe du monde
98 voilà 28 pays sur 32 ont arrêté leur
plan d'hébergement
je lui dis vie décente à 12h58 ouailles
est aujourd'hui 13 voilà vous savez tout
du plan de bataille attention cependant
mirage
il y à une donnée que jamais personne ne
pourra mettre en boîte la capacité
d'improvisation du génie créatif de
l'homme ce qui encore une fois en 80 18
pourrait bien faire la différence à les
aimer comme design les anciens patrons
aux
[Musique]